Good afternoon.
Welcome to Week eight.
So in this week, we're
going to talk about
correlation and
regression. So in terms of
assignment two.
This helps you to
do the Section
two and three a.
Last week we discussed
when we look at the data,
how you inspect
it visually,
find outliers, how you
find problematic data,
and how you
deal with them.
If you deal in a certain
way, for example,
if you plan to
delete it or
impute it with me,
so on and so forth, how
do you justify
those reasons.
That's what we looked
into in the last week.
Today we're going
to look about
correlation and
recreation.
Today's agenda
first, we will
look into what
correlation is and
how we do
correlation analysis
and we have an
activity plan for it.
We'll go through
that activity
to understand a little bit
more deep and then
we'll go through
regression analysis.
In the overall
roadmap of the units.
We are at this
part of analysing
data now and then how we
draw into
conclusions based on
this analysis is what
we are trying
to look into.
Why correlation and
regulation matters?
Can anybody give a
brief understanding
or explanation of what
correlation means?
Yeah. We want to see if
two different datas Two
different variables
are actually related
Related to each other.
Yeah. Makes sense.
And quantitatively
how related? How
related are they?
Yeah. Anybody else?
Any other definitions?
So the last week,
we saw what
problematic data
is there in each column.
We didn't necessarily look
at how each of those are
related to one another.
In correlation, what
you're trying to
see is as he
exactly mentioned,
you're trying
to quantify how
one variable is
related to another.
Now this explains
one important point
when it comes to
your synthetic data
in the assignment
three as well.
Because the reason
why we ask you to
find a more realistic
data that's
related to your topic
is because when you
synthesise data using
general VI models,
what you do is
you mainly give
each variable
a constraint,
you will say, this
is my variable age,
give a distribution of
a standard normal
distribution
along and then pick
the random values greater
than ten, less than 100.
Likewise, you can fit
the variable for that.
But you cannot create
relationship between
variables using a simple
generally way I want.
You will not see
any most meaningful
relationship that you
see in actual data
when you synthesise
it that way.
That is one of the
reasons why we ask you
or encourage you
to pick a data
set that's
closely related.
But that's the
teaching point.
How it relates to
your assignment,
I'll show it to you here.
Maybe as we move on, but
that's the main reason
why we say that.
What is recreation
now we know
what is correlation.
What is recreation?
Any idea? What do they
diverge? Not exactly.
If I give you a
hint in regression,
before I give
between finding
about the medical
relationship
and what you're
right to do with it.
S's how they're
related to each other.
Reach other like
mathematically how they.
You try to model the.
Okay. Any other ideas?
So I region, what
you try to do is
you know certain variables
depend on the other.
So you find your dependent
and the independent
variables,
and you've seen a sample
of data distribution,
and you try to
mathematically fit a model,
in this case,
fit a line or
a linear line or a
plane or something.
Then for unknown cases,
you use that model to
predict the value.
For an example, if
you fit a model
for someone's age
versus income,
you collect the data, you
find the best fitting
lines for that,
and then you
give me any age.
Now based on that line,
I can predict what
is their income.
You get the idea.
Finding that line,
how you find it,
and how you fit
that line is
basically what you.
Here we are trying
to do some predict.
I the as is like
correlation measures,
we the variables move
together and how
strong and in which
direction they move,
I reation, you quantify
and predict it.
It's a model to estimate
the factors effect and
forecast value forecast
values you
haven't observed.
That's a basic idea of
what each of these means.
What correlation
and regulation can
reveal in different
engineering
discipline is
what we see here.
For example, if you
take electrical,
how ambient temperature
effect batteries,
visible capacity.
If you take chemical
engineering,
what reactor
conditions drive
the highest
production yield,
how in mechanical,
how does the
stress aptitude
predict part sat life.
Likewise, you can
find the relationship
between two
variables, right?
Go. The next
important thing
is the purpose of doing
some correlation
is to visualise
the general direction or
the pattern in
the data between
two variables.
When you do your
scatter plot,
you will see clear trend.
Sometimes you see
a increasing trend
or decreasing trend,
or it can be
quite noisy that you
don't see any trend.
How you can measure
it and quantify
it is what we are
going to do when we
do this correlation.
One way of looking at
it is by measuring
the PS and correlation
coefficient.
How do you explain
the intuitive
understanding of what this
means through
this slide and
maybe we'll go to
the equation for
a little bit and
understand how all of
these makes sense.
Mainly what it does,
the purpose is measuring
the strength and
the direction
of a linear relationship
between two
continuous variables.
It mainly ranges from
minus one to plus one.
If you get a plus one,
that means it has
a perfect positive
relationship.
If you have a
negative one,
it means it has
a perfect linear
negative relationship.
If your r is
close to zero,
means no relationship.
The interpretation
is if you take
the modulus and if
it is close to one,
it's a strong association.
If it's close to
zero is weak,
the sign gives you whether
it's positive or negative.
Here are a few key
assumptions that
we have when we
do this correlation
coefficient.
One is you assume a
linear relationship,
you want it to
be the variables
to be continuous
and no major outlas.
One important note is
correlation does
not imply cosation.
We'll understand
each of these
when we do the activity.
But I just take you
to the equation.
Is cardation. Is that
correctly.
All right.
If you look at
the equation
that's used for PS
and correlation.
I'll forget
about this Sigma
denominator for a second.
If you look at this,
what does it me?
X i means each
and every individual
observation
that you have in this
particular variable,
x y is the mean of that.
Yi for the
dependent variable,
here you don't necessarily
me the dependent
independently just look at
two different
variables when
you do the correlation.
Yi is the second variable.
You look for all
the observations,
all of the observations,
and y y is the mean.
Now when you look
at them together.
I the difference
between when
X is increasing beyond me,
me that means if
the screens are
not coming in.
Let me reshare it.
For some reason, I have to
do it twice. I
don't know why.
When you look at these
two differences,
W X observations
are higher
than the mean, what
happens to this val?
It's positive.
Because when you
substrik the mean,
if it's higher than the
mean, it's positive.
If the same happens in y,
same trend happens in y,
what happens in the second
v. That's
positive as well.
When positive
and positive ult
lies, it becomes positive,
that's how you find
the direction
of the trend.
If both of these are
lower than the mean.
Again, this will
be negative.
This will be negative,
multiplication
will be positive.
You still have a
positive relationship.
If one is going one way or
the other is going
the other way,
then the relationship
would become
negative. It's clear.
Now that's how it
gives the direction.
You do it for each and
every observation,
and then you sum it out.
That's what this
summation means.
That's how you get
su value for that,
and then you divide it by
the standard deviations to
get a normalised value.
That's what this
equation basically.
Now if we try to
understand it should
be definitely linear and
why you should not
have outliers,
the equation makes it int.
If you have outlier.
No O gets affects
the mean.
So if you have your
salaries around,
let's say as I explained.
Last week, 30 k 40 k,
50 k around and there is
a guy who is
like 10 million,
20 million,
your mean is going
to get biassed.
And then what happens
is if the mean is
getting biassed,
the equation is going
to get effected and
the correlation
coefficient wouldn't
give better picture
of what it.
And the second
thing it should
always have a linear
relationship.
Give me a perfect example
of a non linear
relationship.
Y equal x
squared. You know
y equal x square is
a nice bell curve.
It's not linear. If you
compute this x y and
y for that, what
will happen?
Because it comes down
and then goes up.
So it will cancel
out and it will
become zero,
R will go close
to zero, right?
So that's why we say you
cannot the relationship,
we assume.
So those are
the few points
based on the equation.
So we have a
small activity
and then if you
go to your cans,
And then if you go
practical correlation
and regulation,
you can do these
two HT files,
and I'll open the
correlation one now.
Yeah. So I'll give you
a couple of minute to
download it and
set it up and
then we'll go through
this together.
Any questions
about correlation?
The first plot
says a survey of
300 working adults records
their age and
annual income.
Before calculating
anything,
look at this scatter plot.
What pattern do you see?
As a strong positive
relationship as age ine,
the income tends to
inc. We clear
relationship.
We have four answers,
but the first one is
the obvious one, right?
So we select this one
and submit
answer and then,
we will be able to see
the actual correlation
coefficient calculator.
So it's 0.92.
It's positive 0.92,
that means it has
a nice positive
relationship
and the value is
close to one,
so it's 0.92, which means
it has a strong
positive relationship.
If you look at some of
the key points to
look in this graph,
it's a textbook example of
PS and correlation working
as it is intended.
The relationship
is approximately
linear and the dominant
you don't see any
dominant subgroups
or anything distorting
the picture,
so it's working
perfectly well.
The basic idea is
you fit it for
the dataset you have
and then once you have
this line fitted,
whenever you want,
whenever you give
it predicts.
You can say what
is the salary.
That's how we fit
this line is what we're
going to learn in region,
but in correlation, you
just calculate
the coefficient.
We'll go to the
next scenario.
Here, the same
survey recortes
daily internet
usage before
looking at R. Age
and internet usage.
When you see this
distribution,
what you can see,
is it a linear
relationship?
No. You can see
in the middle,
when the age is
around 30 to 40,
there is a non linear
curve that goes up here.
It's non linear.
The answer
should be see a non
linear pattern,
middle aged adults
use younger
and younger and
older adults uses.
Select this one. You can
see the relationship is
very weak and
it's negative.
The PS cov measures on
linear relationship and it
measures when there is
a non linear association,
does not reflect that.
That's why we have
this non linear
association.
We'll go to the next one.
Here, you can tuple with
this to see if
there is an outlier
and see what happens to
the coefficient when
you have the outlier
in your
distribution, right?
The answer is
straightforward,
a moderate negative
relationship,
so you can see negative
and it's moderate
when fitness declines
log with age,
and I'll click that
one and then
you can see it
strong linear,
negative association.
You can see what happens
when you put the outlier.
It reduces it by 0.04%,
0.04, non percent
0.04 point.
But the general idea is
if you have much
worse outliers,
the correlation is going
to get affected back.
We need to make
sure we clean
the outliers before
we do any analysis,
that's part of what we
do when we clean data.
This is an
interesting case.
Try to see what
happens here.
In general, while you
think about this
in general,
if you have two clusters.
Imagine that we are
measuring the internet
or the electricity
usage of
the university across
365, in a year.
You will see certain
subgroups during
the weekends.
Be the amount of
electricity usage
in weekends in
Saturdays and Stays,
Sundays, it's going
to be very low.
It's going to
have two groups.
If you have these
groups when you
calculate PS and
correlation coficent,
what's going to
It's going to
impact the mean
and it's not
going to give you
a proper idea of
what you're planning
to calculate.
The bs case is separate
the groups and calculate
them calculated
separately for them.
The answer here should
be two separate clusters.
Another group
is active with
a costing overall
trend. Answer B.
When data contains two
more distinct subgroups,
seers and R captures
the separation
between groups,
not the relationship
within them.
HR is negative, primarily
because the active group
sits in a different
region of the plot,
not because exercise
continuously
reduces heart rate
across individuals.
If you actually
look at this line,
it basically says the
heart rate actually
decreases when you
do exercise more,
so you cannot draw
into a conclusion
like that.
The reason you get
this value here is
because there are
two subgroups
and it can be
misleading, right?
Here the nonsense
correlation.
What it means here is
an intriguing finding.
People who drink more
coffee tend to have
high incomes. Is it true?
What might have been
the reason for this
the plot big? Intuition.
What could be a reason?
No. M. What like a,
it looks like they're
all like the ra.
Is the it going
like upwards?
It's just like
people's age goes up,
they tend to more coffee.
And as age goes up,
the annual income goes up.
Then when you plot
coffee consumption
with annual income,
you try to show some sort
of a strong relationship,
but it's more likely not
caused by the actual
two variables,
so you cannot draw into
for conclusions like that,
so there could be a
third variable, right?
Yeah. We click that on.
Both coffee
consumption and
income income
increases with age.
They appear
correlated with
each other even
though needed causes.
Correlation does not
means any causation.
So that's the main
teaching point, right?
Just because you find
an ice correlation
coefficient between
two variables,
it doesn't mean all
these cases that.
It could be a
different reason.
Two variables that co vary
because they share
a common case.
Here, it's,
not because one
influences the other.
Hs and R cannot
distinguish
a cos relationship
shift from apres one.
The next one, people with
higher social media
usage tend to have
higher fitness s. It
would be interesting.
You spend 5 hours
on social media,
you tend to become
more fit is true.
The plug s t. What
could be the reason.
The same age.
Same age thing.
Younger people more in
social media and they
are more fit as well.
It doesn't mean
anything here.
Just because you see a
positive correlation,
you cannot
interpret it saying
that this is why
this is happening.
B is the answer, the
positive relationship,
but agelly drives
younger people,
you use more social media
and tends to be
fit as well. So
Yeah. Even a higher R,
even large, convincing one
cannot establish
causation.
Here H causes
both high fitness
and high social media,
producing a strong
positive relationship
between them as a
side effect, right?
When you look at it from
your assignments
perspective,
we might have to
do correlation
coefficient to some
variables in your data,
you have to find
meaningful correlations
and you have to interpret
them, justify them.
When you interpret them.
The teaching points we
discuss are what you
need to address.
Sometimes when
you when you plot
those two variables
together,
you might see
two clusters.
In that case, you
might have remove
the clusters,
discuss about it.
The correlation coefficient
gives this value,
but it does not make sense
because there's
two clusters.
How you make
it meaningful.
That is from the
assignment perspective,
and even when
you use it in
the real world scenario,
So in some of these cases
where coffee and all
these social media age.
It's very intuitive,
anybody can understand.
But when you're working
in an engineering context,
you would be
working with more
technical variables
and technical terms.
In those cases, when
you look at correlation
between different
variables,
and if you think,
this is causing
that without
actually understanding
what's causing the effect,
the third variable or
something like that,
then you might be d roving
into very wrong
conclusions.
That's the main
idea here so
Correlation is important.
It finds linear
relationship,
but whatever it finds
may not be true,
it does not imply
any causation in
certain cases.
But in most of the cases,
it's useful as well.
That's the basic idea.
Any questions from
this? A good.
By the end of
this activity.
What we look into is
interpret the sine and
magnitude of pers
correlation coefficient,
describe the direction
and strength.
We understood if it is
a positive or a negative,
strong weak, how
to interpret it.
Explain why a low R
does not mean
no relationship
and identify non
linear patterns
that cannot capture.
We explain the
classic example
equals a perfect
relationship,
but it's non linear and
p correlation
cannot capture it.
Demonstrate how single
extra data point
can substantially change.
We understood mean is
a important factor in
the correlation
coefficient equation,
and when you have
large anomalies or
train data points,
they affect the mean,
so they automatically
affect the
correlation coficent.
You need to clean
them before using it.
Reorganise when a
statistically meaningful
maybe misleading due to
distinct sub subgroups
in the data.
We saw there were
two subgroups
with the heart
rate example.
You can have a
nice relationship,
but because of the groups,
it does not make any
meaningful conclusion.
Distinguish between
a spars correlation
and a causal relationship,
identify plausi
confounding variables
that could explain
and observed
r. W it's not causation,
there could be variables
we discussed this.
Finally valid with the
BSN correlation is
an appropriate
summary statistic
for a given dose
by inspecting the
scattered blot
before reporting
R. R gives you the
quantification.
You gives you more idea,
so you need to use both of
them for the
analysis, right?
All right. So
now we move to
single and multiple
regression.
So now I gave a
brief understanding
of why or how you fit
a line for this one.
So in general, if you have
done any regression,
can a anyone explain
me like how this
line is fitter
and any understanding
of what these statistics,
each of these
statistics mean?
P value if it's
statistically
significant P value?
Yeah statistically the
statistical significance.
That's correct.
What are you're
trying to do
with this entire
regulation,
what you're trying to.
Let's say you have
two variables.
We'll take the same
one, age and income.
And then you go
around, collected
than people with
age and income and
you have that blot.
Now what you're
going to do?
So as you clearly
explained,
we're trying to find
a mathematical model.
So if you assume
a linear relationship,
what is our model here?
Y equal x plus, correct?
So if you say it's
a model, what do.
If you give any X,
I should be able to
tell what y is, right?
So you give me any x?
I'll give you the y
basically the
prediction means here.
So in order to
do that, what
are the two things
that you need to know?
C. Basically in
this context,
when you say you are
fitting a linear model or
a linear line, what
you're trying to do.
You're trying to use
the data to find
n C. Basically when
you have the data,
you try to find the
base fitting line.
When you say finding
the base fitting line,
you find MNC, means what?
The coefficient of
the gradient, C
is the inter set.
That's what we
call when you have
two simple cases
of two variable,
one dependent,
one independent.
It's the data
is going to be
in a 2d2d2 dimensions,
so you need a
line to fit it.
In a line, you can
fit it, right?
If it is more than two,
let's say three variables,
two independent
and one dependent,
so you're going to be
in a three D plane,
but you wouldn't
be fitting.
In this case,
it wouldn't be
a line. It's a plane.
If it is more
than three, we
equal it a hyperfine.
In this case, the
equation becomes
not y equal m x
plus C. Now we have
more variables.
F fact, you write
it intercept as a
zero plus a one
coefficient one,
x one plus two x two plus
v3x3 plus four x four
for whatever the number
of variables you have.
That is what multiple
linear regulation
means. Is that clear?
Perfect. Now, here once
you say we are
fitting a model,
it's not going
to be perfect.
You have to start
from somewhere
and find what is the
base fitting line.
Once you find that
base fitting line,
what are the other factors
you need to consider?
You would have
ten variables.
All of those ten variables
matter for this,
for example,
coffee consumption is is
not important for
predicting the salary.
But it's there in
the d. How do you
see whether each
of these values
are important or not?
The p value. We look
at the p value and
select or design whether
this is statistically
significant or not.
The next important
thing statistics
is to see how good
is your model.
What do you use for
that? The R square.
Scar basically tells
how much variability
of the data your model
captured? High that.
If if it is more than
0.9 or is close to one,
that means it captures
100% of the variability.
If it is lower than
that? I captures lower.
Coefficient, you know what
the coefficient is
Why is standard era?
Now, we predict
each coefficient.
Ta one beta two beta
three, we find
values for those.
Standard error means
how much uncertainty
would each of those
values can get?
When you pick a value like
that, it can be answer.
If it is too uncertain,
it's more pointless
to have that value.
How uncertain is.
The standard error
should go down and
the standard error depends
on the magnitude
of the vale.
Because if you if
beta one or X one
variable is salary,
the variable you're
going to have or
the gradient you're
going to have for
the salary, it's
going to be high.
It's going to be a value
of thousands or
something like that.
For Beta two, you
will have a
different value.
Beta three, will have
a different value.
The standard error between
the variable
standard error,
you cannot have
apple to have a
comparison because
they are scale.
One of the things we
do is we divide it by
the coefficient and see
it's in a
reasonable place,
but that's
something we do.
All right. Now I'll go
through each of these,
but out of what
I explained,
is there any questions?
This regulation and
multiple regulation idea.
Yeah. Limit to the
R squared value
as to what's good enough.
Does what's value?
In order to see
whether the
model has fitted well or
last square if it
is close to one,
it's better.
If it is close to zero,
it means it does
not capture
vari it's more
towards one,
s. Standard five It
depends on the d it
depends on the das.
But one of the things
it's important that you
raise the question is
we have a just square.
That is because when you
have more variables,
when you increase
the number
of variables that you
use for the model,
it could capture noise
and you could say that
R square captures most
of the data correctly.
But the issue is it's not
the effect of you
finding the all
right variables,
but it just
because you added
more and more variables.
Ad r square
penalises that. So
You need to keep
an eye on both.
If you have
more variables,
adjusted r square would be
more meaningful
metric to see
whether how the
model is fitting.
This is the example
here is shown in PIN.
You can use Matlab or
Excel to do this and
all tutorials on
how you do regression with
all of these
different tools
is there in the canvas.
But if I go through
this example for instance.
All of these different
statistics computed.
Here the first line says
we are computing the
Lottery is a dependent
variable using
and region.
For this case, just avoid
we'll ignore region
because region is
a categorical variable
and how you add
categorical variable to
this linear regression
model may be different,
so there could be
different techniques.
Since this is not a
machine learning course,
we will not go into
details of that.
But there are different
techniques you
can use to add
categorical variables.
But for now, we'll just
focus on the literacy.
So when you look
at these balance.
The balance gives
you an idea of
how well the
model is fitted
based on the data points.
He model, we say O is
ordinary lease square,
I believe, and
then the method,
it says the square.
This is basically the
technique that is used
to fit the line.
I start somewhere and
you fit the line,
which has the lease squa,
that's the objective.
What why you have
to square the idea?
I, this is just.
Understand something. Why?
Push ally. If you
don't do the squaring,
if you have a that is
plus i in one case,
minus i in one
case, what happens?
It compensates to each
other. It becomes.
You need to square
it, so you get
a more meaning you
penalise the area without
looking at the sin.
This is one method that we
use and then you
use a number
of observations
and all the other
different metrics here.
When you look
at this potion,
the co basically says
what sort of
relationship it has.
Literacy has
negative relationship
with winning a lottery,
which means if you
are highly literate,
you have less tasks
of winning a lottery.
This is just a
random example,
so I don't think
too much about
the values of the
relationship with pals,
but more or
less the story.
Then you have the
standard era here,
and then you have
the p values.
A, you can see the p
value P value f
literacy is 0.37.
This is 0.00. All of
these different things
we'll discuss in detail.
But in general, recap
what we discussed so far.
Coefficient represent
the expected change in
the corresponding
variable for
one unit change
in the predictor.
It means basically
if you change
one unit in the predictor,
how much the other
thing changes.
Basically if you
move x by one unit,
how much changes is what
the cofent measures.
Standard error measures
the uncertainty
in the estimated
coefficient.
We estimate a
coefficient here.
Uncertainty is
measured by the
standard error.
Smaller values
indicate more
precise and stat
stable asp.
P value assesses
whether to observe
the relationship is
statistically meaningful.
A small p value
suggests that
the predictor is
unlikely to
have no effect.
Unlikely to
Basically what we do
here is we measure
the we measure how
likely the null
hypothesis is becoming
true and then finding
the p value based on that.
If it is less than 0.05,
we say it's a
statistically
significant component.
That means it
has some effect.
If it is greater
than that,
then we say gas.
I statistic evaluates
whether the model as
a whole explains
the variable
better than no model,
which means if you
just use the mean
of variables
as a predictor
or as the fitted line.
And you compare it
with a whole model?
How your model is what
if statistic explain
it evaluates
whether the whole model
useful overall
model is useful,
especially with
multiple predictors.
Then finally, we have the
r square and
the residuals,
R square indicates
how much of
the variability
in the data
is explained by the model.
We discussed this residues
help diagnize whether
the model assumptions are
reasonable or if patterns
remain unexplained.
What is residual
means? Any idea?
Last week we
discussed about
mean square area
and the residues.
If anyone remembers what
happens in these cases.
So after you fit a line,
after you have a
mathematical model,
you should tell
whether it's
how good it is and
how bad it is, right?
So that's that's
the concept of
any machine
learning supervised
learning you do, right?
So what you do is you have
a training data and you
have a testing data.
Training data is
the data that
you used to fit the model.
And test data is not
used during training.
So you fit your model,
and I told you you
give me any X.
I would tell what
Y is, right?
So you compute it
like that based
on the model and
you have some set
of actual values
that model didn't see
when it fitted the line.
And you use that to
see what is the era of
your predict of the model
you fitted, with that,
The actual versus how much
your predicted change
is the residual.
That's the residual.
That's what you
may measure using
the residual plot.
When you take the
root squared errors,
you compute them and
take the square root.
You take the average
and take the square root,
that is root mean
squared error.
If it is a good model,
the root mean square
er, high low.
The error should
be. You compute
these resides at
root square error
for the text set.
You use the train set,
the p values and
everything for
the train set to pick
the best possible mod.
Cool. Now we'll go
through the activity.
I mean, there is
a regression
explorer. It's TL.
I'll open that one now.
I'll give you
a few minutes
just to click
on each of them
and see what the output
is and then we'll
discuss them.
All right, so we'll go
through each
recreation output.
Each statistic and
see what each of them
mean in the English
definition of
The panel shows single
regulation model
predicting
income from age.
The table below displays
five key statistics
from the
regulation output,
a row correspond
to one concept,
and we'll understand each
of what each of them.
H one means the coefficient.
If you click on.
We get the value
of 1,314 for that.
The first question asked
what coefficient
for age 1,314,
what does this
mean in English?
What does it mean
in plain English?
Basically the
tuition of it.
There's a nice
linear relationship.
What's the answer
to this one?
C. For every additional
year of age,
income is expected to
increase by one and $340.
You increase one unit
by in the Xaxis.
How much y goes up
is what basically
the coefficient is.
Cos two things,
the direction.
It's positive, it's
positive direction
and the magnitude,
the size of the change
of outcome in units.
We discussed this.
Now we'll go to
the second one
standard error.
Here we have two models.
One is predicting using
age to predict the income.
The second is predicting
the coffee to pred income.
The question
is, Age income
has standard of 29.
Coffee to income has
a standard of 848.
What does this
difference tell you?
The standard lower
better because
it measures how
much uncertainty
the predicted
coefficient has.
For coffee, they predicted
a coefficient as 6771,
but the standard is 848.
It's a very high one.
The answer should
be the second one,
the H model coefficient
estimate is precise
and stable than
the coffee model.
Show the answer.
The point is standard
error measures
the uncertainty in the
coefficient estimate,
rule of thumb.
If the coefficient is
less than about
twice, it's rece,
The estimate is
too uncertain
to trust. Age coefficient.
If you take age and
divide it by the
standard area,
it's close to 45,
coffee coefficient
and divided
by standard area,
is close to eight.
This is a rule of um.
You can use it
into understanding
because you cannot compare
those two head to head
because they are two
different coefficient.
But in general,
understanding
if it's lower,
it's better.
The next one, the
P. The left model,
use a only a strong
significant predictor.
The right model adds
internet usage
alongside age.
On the left one,
you just use
age and predict ca
For the right one,
you add extra variable.
Right one is a multiple
linear regression model.
When you look at
the P values.
Here, the p value is
calculated for
the whole model.
It's not for each variable.
What can you say?
It's not statistically
significant.
When you add internet
usage to age,
the model performance
goes down.
Be it might be less
significant than a itself.
Age itself is a
strong predictor
and adding
the other variable
is dropping out.
The important part to
note is always it's not
good to add as
many variables
as possible to
predict a model.
You have to be carefully
look at what's better and
what's not better.
The answer is
There is insufficient
evidence
that internet usage has
any explanatory
power beyond
what He already provides.
The P value ask if
there were truly
no relationship between
this predictor
and the outcome,
how likely would
it be to see
a coefficient that
is large by chance,
P equal to f for
internet usage means
it's not earning its
place in this making.
All right. And
lastly r square.
So Arca measures how
much it captures
the variability.
In this one, it
captures most of
the variability.
You can see 0.87.
This one is more
noisy and the model
only captures around 0.17.
The model using only
predict that
has r square of
0.18, what does this mean?
Offical assumption, 18% of
the variable
in the income.
82% remains.
That's what 0.18 means.
Now the residual blot.
What what should
be the answer?
In this residual blot,
there is something
we call the homo C.
It's basically try to
see when you have
the residual blot.
As your value increases,
the variation should
still remain the same.
If you see a fan
like these or if
you see any unusual
shapes as you go higher,
that means the model
has not fitted.
The understanding
for this one,
the residual
residual spread
wide as fitted
values increase,
a fan shape, what
does this suggest?
The spread of errors
is no constant.
The model may
be specified or
missing a non linear term,
that should be the answer.
It's a intero Cacity.
I'll google this
and show it to you.
Spell it wrong
when it's fine.
Ideally, it should be
like this, the
residual blood.
If something like
this happens,
then the model as
basically it means.
F statistic. Here, we
have the mean in
the dotted line.
If you take mean as
a model and you have
your fitted model,
you compare them and
see how good is
your model to
compare to that.
Right? If statistic for
this model is two than 52,
what does this mean?
Whether the model
explains more variance
than simply predicting
the mean income
for everyone.
The statistic become
the most important
in multiple
regression where you
want to know if the
full set of predictors
collectively
justifies the model.
Even if some individual
predictors are weak,
a large if a significant
f value means the model
as a whole adds
explanatory value.
All right. Now we have
a multiple linear
regation model to fit.
So we have five
different predictors,
and we are going
to predict
the income, right?
So we'll go one by one.
What would be one of
the approaches
that you have to
follow in a multiple
linear regation problem?
How do you find
what variables
are significant
and what are not?
What approach would
be? Go one by one.
That is one standard
approach that we follow.
We try to put
everything together,
and then we remove the
most insignificant
one first,
fit it again and
see how it works.
Likewise we go. Now if
I show you one example,
if I e u,
all six of them.
You can see the p value
is significant on for one.
A, all the others.
Let's not impact here.
We'll remove the
highest one,
it's the coffee
consumption.
Now you can see
after I remove it,
the under values
change a little bit.
For example, for ication,
early eight was 87.
Now you can see it's 881.
After you remove
a variable,
we need to fit it again.
That's the idea. Then you
remove one as you go.
Now I remove. See
what happens.
After I remove, certain
variables that are
not significant before has
become significant.
Why is this?
Yeah. When age is gone,
the most explained
variable is gone.
And out of the
remaining variables
trying to do a good job,
the next one try to
see what is most
significant out of all
of those. That's
the reason.
One good approach as we
discussed earlier
would be to
use all of them together
and then remove as we go.
In certain
cases, you might
find some interesting
scenarios.
There are here are
some events
trigger. Let's say
For the first time, with
all six predictors
included
several p values above
0.05 and some
standard errors
have grown compared
to simpler models.
What is most like
clear explanation?
It should be
the second one.
Labour multi correlating
means each correlate
to other ones,
for example, age
correlates with
the fitness and age
correlates with the inco,
something like that.
If we remove, internet
age and coffee.
Certainly etc,
right? All right.
So you look at the r
squared just a r square,
statistic and
the R M C value.
And here we have the res.
So those are the
important things to
look at when you're
fitting a model.
Any questions on this?
The main point is
when you're doing
your assignment
and when you're
fitting your
regression model
with all the variables,
you would start
and you would not
get the best
fitting model,
and then you may
have to see what are
the statistical
significant variables,
remove them and fit it
again, do all of these.
All of those
plots cannot be
maybe included
in the answer for
the questions.
When you have the
justification discussion,
you can add those
different plots
in the appendix and
maybe discussed.
When you add all of
those variables,
the p values were
these and we removed
it in this
procedure to find
out this is the
significant one and then
you add a discussion
or interpretation to
it based on that.
So that's what we
expect and that's
why we have
this example here to
understand the impact of
having what's
happening with these.
Here we have
the real block.
So you can see
it here and root
mean square means how
the error computed on.
Here in your assignment,
you will have we will
specify what is your
trade set and
the test set.
So if you go to assignments,
assignment two,
It clearly says
it's highlighted
to answer the question
in this section,
please split the
data set as follows.
Use data from first
January 24 to December 31
inclusive as
training set and
use remaining data
as the testing set.
For an example, if you see
the CPI discuss any
model simplification,
that is removal
of independent
variables from the model.
Why with the appropriate
justification,
discuss the impact of
simplifying the model
on performance.
For those, you need to
do what we've
discussed, right?
Now we'll go to
the final part.
V your model. So, I'll
give you a couple
of minutes.
Try to find the model,
select the variable
a way that you find
the base model
with all variables
being statistically
significant.
And the value the R
square being the highest,
O the adjusted R square
being the highest.
Se.
Basically try to build
the model with the
highest adjusted SCA,
when every
included predictor
has p value below 0.05,
one predictor in
this data and has
no real relationship
with sale price,
finite and exclude it.
We'll add one by
one, flow area.
P value 0.05, Ask
adjusted eight.
You add more variables.
You look for the
adjusted when you
add more variables because
it makes more sense.
And then you have
building age.
It increases it to 89.
I'll atrate
number, whatever.
It is statistically
insignificant.
Variable. If I have
that without now
you can see it is
0.9 with flow
area being there,
I remove flow area,
it goes down to 0.2,
but still it is
insignificant.
That's why we say
starting from
all the variables
and removing
the highest
insignificant one and
then fitting it again
and much better approach.
I add the
distance as well.
It is 0.922 removing
the straight number.
That's the best
model that we can
fit in. Once we add this,
You can see the set
what happens to
the RMC
and the other vals,
we need to
remove this one.
You will follow
a second process
in your assignment
as well.
So that's pretty much
what we have to discuss
in this activity.
Now we'll go back
to the slides.
So by the end of
this activity,
you will be able
to interpret
the region coefficient
in English,
including its
direction, magnitude,
and units. We
spoke about this.
How what direction is
given by the sign.
The value tells you
the magnitude and
basically what that
predictive variable
takes as the unit is
what the unit is.
Basically for one
unit, how much it
changes is what the
coefficient measures.
Explain what standard
era indicates
about the reliability of
a coefficient estimate.
It basically measures how
certain the predicted
coefficient is.
Use the p value
to assess whether
predictor contributes
meaningfully
to a model, so
you use the p value
as an indicator
to find whether
the variable
is statistically
significant or not.
R square in general
measures how much of
variable in the data is
captured by the
model, higher beta.
Identify a spurs or
redundant predictor
using p values and changes
in adjusted R square. So
If you add a statistically
significant variable,
what happens to square and
adjusted R square is
what we discussed here.
You have to make
sure you pick
the statistically
significant ones.
Distinguish between a
specified model and
one that is underfitting
or over specified.
This is what we
discussed in terms
of the residual lots.
The form and
the other one.
When you have the
residual lot,
you look for the
nice distribution.
If it has any
patterns that means
it's underfitting
or specified.
Then finally,
you have this
interactive quiz agent
for each module,
so you can use
this link and then
as your knowledge.
Finally, as a
wrap up, today,
we discussed correlation
and causation.
Correlation shows
some association
between variables.
What it means, you
have to interpret it.
It does not make any sense
in terms of cause
and effect.
You have to interpret
it carefully.
Interpreting coefficient
cohesion indicates
the direction
and magnitude of
a relationship in a
regression model.
Check P values and
confidence intervals
for significance.
Regression helps to
predict outcomes
and quantify relationship
between variables.
In multiple linear
recreation,
we use multiple variables,
and then you pick
what variables
makes more sense,
make sense based
on the p values,
and then you fit the base
model based on that.
Understand assumption.
Here in linear reduction,
we basically assume
the distribution
or linear.
The model is fitted
based on that.
And independent. They are
independent variables and
homoskcity is what I
mentioned earlier.
The area should
be consistent
for valid models.
Some homework work on the
correlation and
regression tasks
in assignment two.
If you go to assignment
two, I think
The Section three,
Section two is
on correlation.
Section three is on
multiple linear
regression.
You can do both
of them now.
The last one
is about using
the synthetic and
real world data
set and doing
some analysis.
Try to find
some data sets.
In the next
class, we would
see how we can
generate some of
these data sets and
then some he section
for assignment could be
done in the next class.
That's it for
the material.
So if you have
any questions,
I'd be happy to answer.